it's here it's arrived in the arrival
trailer it's arrived greg has arrived
john has arrived we've arrived to arrive
this let's do it really well shot a man
steal
bye everyone
but anyone get your body to be able to
be working with in the shop that's what
they call me
he's being herded off in the medevac
soon enough everything looks great man
I mean this looks like the kind of movie
that would have come out
Thanks
this is 112
baby step down
it's their language
ensuring they understand the difference
between a weapon at all
language is messy and sometimes one boss
really in their language it's possible
they're probably us to fight among
ourselves this is just a way to force us
toward to give the fluence it's more
complicated thing
I don't think more complicated Russia
just executed one of their own to keep
their secret for me it's not more no
more clarify their intentions go back in
what a cool opportunity for that guy I
draw my eye contacts going dry right as
play cuz I didn't blink that whole time
that was a great trailer it's a pretty
sweet trailer I feel like I don't see
enough great trailers like that there
was a small second there where I got a
little worried it was gonna go all too
crazy but then it didn't
yeah it went around a little bit went
around the world and stuff and we saw
some cool shots of [ __ ] at the end of
the day it still seemed more grounded I
feel like the hashtag for this film
works what is it why are they here why
are they here what does trailers making
me ask oh yeah it is making because it
doesn't seem like they're out to destroy
and then it's like they're more are they
manipulating us that's a cool kind of
concept to go down and it seems like an
inspiration honestly from like a
Spielberg meets Ridley Scott it feels
more really Scott to me just cuz it
looks very like intense it's sort of
scoping in it's a story of the of the
world and this sort of logistics the
military side of this you know the
effect it has on people exactly no I
totally agree that I don't get as much
wonder as I would a Spielberg hear me
out here alright allow me to introduce
you to a new form of thought here you
see when the starfish showed up that was
weird
because you know I like I'm sure a lot
of people probably expected some loud
bang kind of cracks the glass or
something I don't know that doesn't
happen it's just a starfish it's
Pleasant and then for like 5 to 10
seconds there it felt like this could be
a thing cuz Amy Adams this character
seems to be fascinated and takes and
cares about these creatures there is a
mystery of like like support and love
and Wonder and awe towards these aliens
from her perspective I feel like we'll
be in there but I feel like it will be
more like alien in tone or like district
matters that you like or it just will be
its own thing I hope so it seems like
this guy's gonna tell I'm going around
in a real world version of this story
and it looks really cool like I like
that they're taking time to be like
we're gonna try and communicate with
them as best as possible both yeah where
we start making a lot of decisions
that's what I love about it because
usually an alien invasion
and once the aliens make their presence
known they're [ __ ] up the world the
only movie that kind of didn't do that
was Mars Attacks mm-hmm
remember there's a scary [ __ ] movie
when I was growing yeah right it was
gardens to both Jack Nicholson
characters were connected because I was
confusing for me yeah yeah real violent
13 but ya know this movie looks cool I
like the first have the trailer better
than the second half of the trailer but
I feel like it's good cuz the first half
like we saw in the teaser it just has
more breathing space so that clues me in
on what this movie probably feels like a
second half of the trailer is very much
like here are a lot of major plot points
and really big visuals I think the
second half is maybe a little too big
for me just because I don't know where
the rest of the movies gonna land in
terms of these tones but I feel like
they're kind of marketing this way to
you cuz this is almost seems like
something on the scale like what
Christopher Nolan would do now it's a
heady sci-fi movie or at least it looks
like it's taking a lot of time for
nuance while being a sci-fi action movie
it's also we're gonna market it to the
masses it's like it's more interesting
than your normal [ __ ] but it's also
really cool like and that's kind of what
I feel this movie is gonna be cuz this
is a guy who clearly makes films like
you know people really liked prisoners
in Sicario and and the one the other one
he did was Jake Jonah oh I read I mean
I've heard good things about everything
so this seems like this is his what's
your dream project Dennis this looks
really cool I'm glad they gave him money
for this because this looks like a
pricey piece I think it looks like your
very film yeah it looks really cool I
just gotta say and Lois Lane stop
getting involved in so many aliens first
guy on the Internet to make that joke
comment or video that was me
joke a minute with this one get Hawkeye
stop getting mixed up with aliens so
much oh yeah I wonder what he's gonna do
it's not as personal so it doesn't work
cuz he counters like a villain well yeah
and him and now other context he's got
powers and stuff like what was happening
is Hawk
I doesn't want to let himself get
manipulated by these aliens better not
work in secret past this is what Hawkeye
doesn't now and this is Forest Whitaker
you know trying to make up for
everything that went wrong in species
County but now is the time it's like
finally I've been waiting my whole
career no I mean as a character in the
movie species because a lot went wrong
natasha Henstridge killed a lot of
people so this is him making up for that
I didn't see this equals the species
see how there's I kind of wonder vibe
from her yeah it's just the government
is like we don't trust you see she keeps
getting involved with alien that the
government just don't trust she keeps
getting involved with aliens and then
she also works a lot of people with
access to guns oh she had to have known
she was gonna get jokes like Amy a bomb
actress
I hope this this character allows her to
have a bit more of a range of
personality to them and some of the
recent stuff we've seen you're just
talking about the DC movies
well yeah but you know what just what
there's hustle she was awesome I have no
doubt in my mind about her wrench cuz
I've seen her be terrific in a lot of
movies I just don't want them to keep
her in this sort of one mode like the
Superman movie thing I just want to say
you played all levels of attractiveness
she came off like Victor catch me if you
can yeah I was like Ryan that's that was
her like big break
Oh and she was like goofy nerdy yeah
she's adorable and cute ever since I've
seen her then she did girls extra
chanted you know adorable and cute
really pretty princes like princess like
and and I don't know the order of all
your film isn't then you did a doubt
where you were like you know I got
really hot that was the whole point is
to doubt if she was hot or not you
couldn't man cuz I can't see the rest of
you here pass me a middle done man oh
but in the fighter
dude tough she wasn't like basta shoot
adorable like you know princess she was
very much like what really don't [ __ ]
with ya she looked like she would like
crack a glass on your header to bar yeah
pull off that accent well - yeah yeah
what American hustle I mean she's got to
play like a fake human beat and she has
to exhibit a whole range of
manipulations in motion and stuff like
she's terrific in that movie and she's
like super 70's foxing oh yeah
Amy Adams and then she played a
cardboard cutout of Steve stop with the
matter sealed right now see you all
right guys hey the subscribe button has
arrived reasons the Jerry has arrived
facebook.com slash the real rejects and
the blue house 1/2 has arrived
you know who's arrived Amy Adams Amy you
come a long way since psycho beach party
ooh that's a lot better than